with the unfolding crisis in louisiana
where many people are still struggling
to cope with the aftermath of hurricane
ida more than half a million people are
without power more than a week after the
storm
in new orleans the heat index yesterday
was 102 degrees and many communities
still don't have enough food water and
other essential supplies meanwhile an
investigation is underway into
conditions at a warehouse where hundreds
of nursing home residents rode out the
storm officials say conditions were
unsafe and ordered seven senior living
facilities that sent patients there to
close jessie mitchell is outside of that
warehouse jesse good morning
good morning dana the nursing home
patients forced to endure hurricane ida
in the building behind me have since
been transferred to other housing the
state department of health shut down
those seven nursing homes that brought
them here we spoke with one nurse who
saw firsthand the desperate conditions
inside
they were hungry they were thirsty
they was crying for you know out there
was in pain
it was just very sad
nurse natalie henderson wrote out the
hurricane inside a warehouse here in
independence louisiana where hundreds of
nursing home residents were packed in
just before ida hit these images show
patients on mattresses on the floor with
no social distancing health officials
were told the residents were not being
fed or changed five of the seven deaths
here were storm related the whole place
is reeking of urine and feces
on top of them trying to eat
they begging for water the owner of the
seven nursing homes behind the move
tried to downplay the tragedy last week
we only had five deaths within the six
days normally with 850 people you will
have a couple a day so we did really
good on taking care of people why would
you say that it shouldn't be no debts at
all
at all it's just heartbreaking some
residents in some of the hardest hit
louisiana towns have given up facing
sweltering heat gas and food shortages
they're leaving the state until the
power returns any place the lord blesses
us to go out of this heat where we're
able to get some food get a hot bath and
you know in just some comfort meanwhile
henderson says after speaking out she's
been told she'll never be hired back if
the nursing homes reopen but she hopes
doing so will ensure nothing like what
she witnessed will ever happen again
these are people's lives they are not
animals or dogs they are human beings
and they deserve
good treatment
the louisiana department of health
reports trying to inspect this facility
after hurricane ida they were not
allowed access meanwhile cbs news has
reached out to bob dean jr the nursing
home owner for comment he has not
responded to our request jerica jesse
mitchell thank you